time now for our Friday Follies look at
some of the cultural stories just
beneath the media radar what to do with
me to movement
Oscar swag bags in a world war one
Memorial all have in common let's get
into that good stuff with Fox News
contributor Raymond Arroyo okay Oscar
weekend get the pop all right it's name
not watch Oscar swag bags tell me what's
going on here in the Oscar swag bag as
you know tell me what they are
well the me to movement has cast a long
shadow over this Oscars yeah they're
trying to escape the sexual
indiscretions of the misconduct but I'm
the official swag bag $100,000 swag bag
which all the presenters and actors and
presenters receive in it is pepper spray
to repel attackers body alarms should
you be touched inappropriately and wait
wait for this a drink test to make sure
your drug your drugs have not been
placed in your drink now if you're
trying to get away from the me to thing
and trying to get away from sexual
misconduct why is that in the swag bags
it's a reminder that you may be attacked
at the Governor's Ball I guess alarm but
they get those bags when they're a
presenter or recipient oh yeah and they
get free used to get like Tiffany's
Tiffany's stuff these are getting good
stuff now they're getting some shower to
me to action survivor kid all right what
about this Harvey Weinstein statue the
billboards in LA okay Harvey Weinstein
statue just went up in downtown LA and
it is he in a bathrobe okay and it's
called the casting couch now the dirt
the creator of this a guy named plastic
Jesus I can't explain the name guy he
had this to say about his creation Alton
yeah we picked the Oscar time
specifically because there's so much
focus on the awards at this time of year
but as everybody knows Hollywood like so
many other industries has this dark
underbelly which often goes ignored or
in this case has even been covered up
and worse he's kind of a combo of the
Grim Reaper and Phantom of the Opera
with what is that he's an artist he's
expressing himself but here's the
prospects evil hollow look up
work and there being at MoMA they are
being really attacked from all sides
their billboards all over LA the calling
them out but here's the problem when the
scandal is bigger than your movies
that's a huge difficulty for them there
is it any wonder that viewership plunged
to a nine year low
last year and I don't know and watch the
Olympics the Olympics is way down right
this is all everything's political then
why are you doing me two movements in
the in the ceremony that's supposed to
celebrate your great movies as I asked
you earlier what do you think is gonna
win the Oscars this year Laura Ingraham
don't know you didn't even see these and
most of your audience didn't either and
that's the problem
I'm scandal you know what I think they
should have it the Oscars they should
just have one of those dressing room
you know coat hangers and it should just
be a white bathrobe empty on the stage
when that just a white is like it's just
hanging by itself that'd be creepy if
they want to have if they want to be
self-reflective and really address the
me to movement talk about the
misogynistic and violent program area
you shove out into the clock what's
behind this effort now speaking of our
atheist friends previous segment to
remove the peace cross Memorial in
Maryland this is a picture loss yeah
this cross has stood here in Maryland
for a hundred years the American Legion
and private families put this up to
honor World War one veteran's will show
a picture of it in a second the American
Humanist Society said this needs to be
taken down in the front and two courts
have now said including an appellate
court it should be removed so this is
gonna have to go to the Supreme Court
well that's gonna be taken down why why
remove every vestige of our veterans as
well as their religious experience here
David private funds built this let's
tear down their hair down society we're
gonna tear it all down they're saying
tax money is used to maintain it alright
and finally I think one of the most
moving moments and one of the most
trench and pieces of commentary over the
week came from a surprising source
someone we don't agree with much from
House Minority Leader Nancy Pelosi
there's a commensurate bipartisan a
common-sense bipartisan support that
would be Mike Thompson is of California
who's the chair of our tax Wars task
force just thirteen percent would go to
bonuses and raise raises
six million middle-class families excuse
me eighty-six million middle-class
families enhancement as they go out to
the public sector private sector the
private sector get that gavel soon
can someone diagram those things there's
no editing there but was fair but just
says you have to cook look at Santa it's
just late in the week because I'll read
the transcript we're gonna write